president trump meanwhile campaigned in
pennsylvania yesterday on the same day
another of his former close associates
was put in handcuffs former white house
chief strategist steve bannon was
arrested
on fraud charges over an alleged scheme
connected to the president's
long-promised border wall
he was later released on a 5 million
bond paula reed is following all this
from the white house
as he left federal court in manhattan
steve bannon suggested the trump justice
department's case against him is a setup
well i feel very badly i haven't been
dealing with him for a long period of
time president trump tried to distance
himself from his former chief strategist
who prosecutors allege was part of a
group that raised more than 25
million dollars to build a southern
border wall then
stole hundreds of thousands of dollars
in donations for themselves
i know nothing about the project other
than i didn't like when i read about it
i didn't like it
bannon pleaded not guilty to charges of
wire fraud and money laundering and was
released on a 5 million dollar bond
after being arrested that morning on a
yacht off the coast of connecticut
bannon is the president's sixth close
associate to be criminally charged by
trump's own justice department
what's it say about your judgment that
these are the kind of people
thursday afternoon president trump hit
the campaign trail near joe biden's
childhood hometown of scranton
pennsylvania
there's only one thing standing between
your family and the radical left-wing
mob
and that's your vote this november as
biden was formally accepting the
democratic nomination for president
mr trump called into fox news with new
attacks
i can't imagine they're ever going to
endorse anybody's going to endorse
biden because they really have a very
unsafe policy for our country
and repeated his baseless claims about
universal mail-in voting
they're trying to steal the election
this will be the most fraudulent
election in history
a former member of the postal service
board testified before lawmakers
yesterday
that the current postmaster general
louis de joy was selected to run the
organization
even though he was the quote least
qualified dejoy will have the
opportunity to respond to that criticism
and answer questions about how he's been
running the postal service
when he appears on capitol hill later
today gail we'll be following that
postal service story thank you very much
paula